Y yo no podría explicar, ni tan solo a mí, mates,
que después de pasar
si sanjimich de fanzana presidencial, exili,
ahora que sobra la oportunidad
para hacer posible la restitución de aquella
presidencia injustamente
ilícitamente ilegalmente instituida,
al 155, ahora que sobra que esta oportunidad,
yo de fugiza, que esta responsabilidad
para los de comunidad personal,
esparchó,
que decidí presentarme a las properas de la acción
autorlavenda, Cataluña
sé que hará parar a la opción de 1 lista unitaria
de poderosas resistencias,
y es evidente también que a Tesa la precipitación,
aunque se, aunque se Han convocado, que estas alacciones
no dispusen 2 plagadas del temps necesari para vence,
que estas resistencias
de xiao'an Tian también, que igualmente en BC,
y no Dara que hay Allen
de diversas sensibilidades,
que hay traballa
de manera discreta y honesta,
para arriba, ferupusipla,
y a ellos voy a expresar la nueva disponibilidad de
contribuir, que estas Force,
para que que estas Force no se acabe
al día de las elecciones,
Lem, de continuar, no podemos dejar,
por eso te enclatan,
ve que la candidatura que voy a encapsular
ahora dan a mis aliados, que es al mejor partido